y vamos a hablar de la champions league
que quiere ser más atractiva si llegara
a más audiencia de la champions league
tal y como la conocemos va a
experimentar un revolcón a partir de la
temporada 2024 2025 veamos de qué se
trata desde esta campaña no habrá 32
equipos en la primera fase sino 36 es
decir 4 nuevas plazas cómo se van a
otorgar se añade un equipo que viene de
la fase previa ya no serán cuatro clubes
sino cinco los que lleguen desde esta
instancia otro equipo será el tercer
clasificado del quinto país con el mejor
coeficiente de la uefa se añade una
plaza de esta manera y luego habrá otros
dos clubes que van a ser para dos
equipos que sí que sean de dos países
cuyas ligas hayan tenido la mejor
actuación colectiva la temporada pasada
en otras palabras en las ligas que hayan
tenido un mejor promedio de puntaje esas
ligas van a poder tener dos equipos
clasificados a la liga de campeones otro
cambio viene la primera fase se acaba la
actual fase de grupos por una liga suiza
cada uno de los 36 equipos va a jugar
cuatro partidos en casa y cuatro
partidos de visitante en esta liga
frente a los demás integrantes los
primeros 8 van directamente a octavos de
final y luego del noveno al que termine
en la plaza número 24 van a jugar una
eliminatoria para decidir los otros ocho
clasificados la idea raúl es que todos
los partidos de esta primera fase sobre
todo sean muy atractivos